hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his treaties on the anger of God one
of the side issues that lactancius veers
off into and provides what he takes to
be a solution to is what we've nowadays
come to call the problem of evil in the
philosophy of religion and you know it's
essentially saying if God is so great
and arranges things and understands what
God is doing and is good then why do we
see all these bad things happening in
the world and this is something that
even in Antiquity there were a lot of
positions on and considerations of as
we're going to see the epicureans the
stoics the academics all discuss this a
Christian philosopher like lotancius in
some respect can't avoid it and not just
with respect to anger which he does
provide a justification for later on in
the trees why did God give us this you
know capacity this emotion that can
sometimes go bad well there's a point to
that but in the broader sense
how should we understand the created
universe and lactancias in chapter 10 is
after you know surveying a number of
different other people's ideas and
saying we can see some consensus among
them
um what can we say he says that there is
a Divine Providence meaning that there
is an arrangement of things and how can
we describe this well he says that
reason declares that there is indeed a
system an arrangement uh a regularity
and he describes these you know he's
very good at rhetoric such a vast system
of things a magnitude right
um such Arrangement and such regularity
so Arrangement is dispositio you know
putting things where they belong and
regularity Constantia
uh and a regularity in what in
preserving the settled orders and times
it could never at first have a risen URI
is coming to being without what a
Provident
artificer a a maker right uh somebody
who forms the things and then he talks
interestingly about God being an
inhabitant as being within uh the world
and then God being a ruler guberator
right uh running things in this vast
Universe
um
perpetually governed without a skillful
and intelligent ruler reason itself
declares this whatever itself has reason
must have Arisen from reason and it goes
on reason is the part of an intelligent
and wise nature but why is an
intelligent nature can be nothing other
than God so he's asserting a very strong
conception a robust conception of
Providence here and then he's going to
take this up again in Chapter 13 where
he's going to consider
several different positions and he
begins chapter 13 by noting something
that the stoics do seem to have held as
a Doctrine
the world was made on our account and he
says well this is actually true so the
world is constructum mundum constructum
right it has been made it has been
constructed it has been formed on our
account Nostra causa for us for us human
beings for us rational beings okay so
this T seems to be a you know rather uh
unproblematic stoic position
unproblematic in the sense that we have
other places that attest this to be
their position it is a little bit
problematic as we're gonna see from
other perspectives but let's go on with
it for a moment he says that all the
world all that the world consists in or
brings into being or generates uh all of
these things he goes on
um are adapted to the use of human
beings so okay
the human race we could say utility the
usefulness the capacity to turn to
things he actually also uses the word
utitur a little bit later to make use of
right so everything within the world is
the way it ought to be it's you know
provided to us how wonderful and then
well we get some proverbial flies in the
ointment with the academics coming
around the Skeptics and saying wait a
second that doesn't seem to make sense
here's an objection to you there's a
whole bunch of things in the world that
seem opposed to or hostile or even
injurious to human beings so why in the
hell would you pass possibly assert that
everything within the cosmos is for us
human beings think about parasites right
you know maybe some parasites are good
because they keep other parasites out or
something like that but that's one evil
replacing another or you know let's take
some other examples from ancient times
earthquakes terrifying you know
something that happened quite often in
the ancient world how are you going to
say that that is actually something good
for us human beings or plagues or
getting old uh you know the seasons
being the way they are uh perishing of
thirst and sunstroke in the summer dying
of exposure and you know frostbite and
cold in the winter these all suck right
so what are you stoics on about and like
tanzia says well the stoics do have a
response it's just not a very good
response he says
um that you know you can you can claim
that the things that we think are
opposed hostile and jurious to us are
actually not so he says the stoics say
there are many things among natural
Productions and reckoned among animals
the utility of which escapes notice but
this is discovered in the process of
times as necessity and use have already
discovered many things which were
unknown in previous ages so the utilitas
of these things escapes us we just don't
see it at this time there is some
helpful thing to it and solectancius
goes on and he says what utility can be
discovered in mice all right and we and
we might in our own time say well
ecologically you know the mice occupied
important nature or something like that
and then he says what about beetles what
about serpents which are Troublesome and
pernicious to man is it that some
medicine lies concealed in them if there
is any it will at some time be found out
namely as a remedy against evils whereas
they complain that it is altogether evil
they say the Viper when Burlington
reduced to ashes is a remedy for a bite
of the same beast and then he says okay
let's say we buy into that
doesn't that seem a weird way for God to
have set things up you know waiting for
us human beings to figure out later on
that we can use these things that we see
as injurious to Medicine he says how
much better had it been that it should
not exist at all than that a remedy
should be required against it drawn from
itself and you know this is a pretty
good argument and then he provides what
he takes to be a better answer and you
know this is an interesting one I'm not
sure how compelling many people will
find it
so he says when God formed the human
being in their his own image that which
was the completion of his workmanship he
breathed wisdom into the human being
alone so that the human being might
bring all things into subjection to his
own authority and government and make
use of all the advantages of the world
and yet he set before him both good and
evil things inasmuch as he gave to him
wisdom the whole nature of which is
employed in Discerning things evil and
good no one can choose better things and
know what is good unless he knows at the
same time to reject and avoid the things
which are evil so these are mutually
connected with each other the one being
taken away the other must be taken away
therefore good and evil things being set
before it wisdom does its job right
discharges its office so the the
argument here is that well without there
being evils
um you're you're not actually going to
have the opportunity to exercise wisdom
right Desiring uh the good for
usefulness rejecting the evil for for
safety he says if only good things are
placed in sight what need is there of
reflection of understanding of knowledge
of reason right and this is actually
going to play a role as well in the next
thing that he's going to consider which
is
epicurus's classic argument from Evil
which he phrases in this way so at
epicurus had said that God either wishes
to take away evils and is unable so
that's option one or
um God is uh able and is unwilling right
or he's neither willing nor able or he's
both willing and able
so we've got four different
possibilities here and epicurus is
actually going to throw one of these out
altogether he says if God is willing to
take away evils and is unable well then
he's not much of a god at all he's
feeble this is a problem because we
could certainly imagine a better God who
would be strong enough to remedy the
evils that his creatures human beings
encounter and suffer he goes on and he
says
um
if he is uh
able and unwilling well then we've got a
problem right then he is envious he
suffers from this Vice of Envy also not
becoming of God right so we've ruled out
two possibilities right off the bat by
saying that this can't be the way that
we understand God and then he goes on
and says if he's neither willing nor
able that he's both envious and feeble
therefore not God and then he says if he
is willing and able which is alone
suitable to God
well then why the hell do we have evils
what is the source of evils if God is
able to take them away and is willing to
take them away why the hell doesn't he
and
lactancia says that
um you know this actually does raise an
issue for quite a few people but from
his perspective uh it's not really a
problem he says that having examined the
matter we easily do away with this
argument God is able to do whatever he
wishes there's no weakness nor Envy in
God he is able therefore to take away
evils but he does not wish to do so and
yet he is not on that account envious so
we have something like a paradox here
what can get us out of this problem
God can take away the evils but he's
he's not doing so but he's not doing so
because of enviousness
well there's a greater good that is
resulting from it and it's this greater
good of wisdom he says that
um he doesn't take them away because at
the same time he gives wisdom and there
is more of goodness and pleasure and
wisdom than of annoyance in evils so
this is saying you know things come out
better by giving people wisdom even
though you know the world is kind of a
messed up place and then he goes on and
adds another thing wisdom causes us even
to know God by that knowledge to attain
to immortality which is the chief good
so unless we first know evil we will not
be able to know good we can't have the
good of wisdom which works on
understanding both goods and evils
unless there's evils in the world
doesn't mean that there's going to be
evils in the afterlife or you know at
least the Heavenly afterlife or being
with God
but certainly here we need them in order
to have these intellectual capacities
operating and so he goes on and he says
for the sake of a slight gain in taking
away evils we would be deprived of a
good which is very great and true and
peculiar to us
and he says he concludes the chapter
it's plain all things are proposed for
the sake of human beings as well evils
as Goods so this is a very interesting
approach to the traditional problem of
evil instead of saying you know God's
mysterious ways or you know some sort of
hand-waving thing like that he's
providing an argument that has to do
with what we could call the development
of the human being opt to being able to
know God as being the product of a
universe that does contain genuine bad
things for us human beings